- So, this talk is about DynamoDB.
I'm gonna start with this one,
which is probably a better talk.
It's like...
(crowd clapping)
You guys didn't wanna give
me a round of applause.
Come on, start.
(crowd cheering)
Okay.
I did not expect this slide here.
Do you have any idea
what the slide is about?
I just thought-
- [Craig] This is your slide.
- Okay, so this is probably an indication
for you how the rest of
this talk is gonna go.
Craig and I worked
together for several years.
My name's Amrith.
I'm the guy on the right here.
We worked together for several years,
but we go back and forth a heck of a lot.
That's what you're gonna
see during this talk.
Both of us work on DynamoDB.
He's Craig, I'm Amrith.
What I've found in the
last six or so years
that I've worked in DynamoDB, in AWS,
is that customers who build
applications on DynamoDB
need to understand not
only how the service works,
but also how we made some of the decisions
about how the service works.
So, this talk is more about
how we made those decisions.
This is who we are.
The exact decisions we made
may not be relevant to you,
but what I hope you
will take away from this
is how we come about those decisions.
Because those may be more
applicable to you as well.
So, the way in which
as a large organization
making a service like Dynamo,
I think, somebody here is
wondering which talk they're in.
This is the DynamoDB talk, okay?
The objective is if you have a large team
and you need to make
everybody in the team able
to be productive at their maximum level,
you cannot have centralized
decision making.
We build a distributed database.
The idea is you want to distribute
things across many nodes
and have the power of many nodes.
What's the point in having a team
which has one decision maker?
No point.
So, we have tenets in DynamoDB
and these give the team an understanding,
a shared understanding,
so that we can push down decision making
into the organization.
This is something which I
think you should understand.
This is how we work at Amazon.
This is something which is
common to all AWS services.
It helps teams make decisions.
And these are our tenets.
First, security.
Second, durability.
Third, availability.
These are non-negotiable.
I don't care what the feature
or the implementation choices,
I will never trade security
in order to give you something else.
And what's the fourth one down there?
Predictable (low) latency.
This is a DynamoDB feature.
We wanna guarantee predictable
(low) latency at any scale,
but we will never trade one of those.
So, in the rest of this
talk, what you're gonna hear
is a reiteration of these tenets.
Security, durability, availability,
and predictable (low) latency.
These need not be the
tenets in your organization,
but as a decision maker
in your organization,
the thing I would urge you to do
is think about what these tenets are.
Make sure that everybody in the team
has a shared understanding of these tenets
so that when they're making a decision,
they will understand
what these tenets are.
Now, in the rest of this talk,
we're gonna talk about
these over and over again,
but many of these choices
are gonna come down to
predictable (low) latency.
Because like I said, security, durability
and availability are non-negotiable items.
So, if we have to give you
predictable (low) latency...
Just show of hands, how many
of you here use DynamoDB?
And how many of you have
never used DynamoDB?
Never used DynamoDB, show of hands?
All right, very small number.
The rest of you understand, we try
to give you predictable single
digit millisecond latency
at any scale.
So, with that, let's talk about-
- All right, all right,
you've talked enough.
- All right, this is how it
usually works with Craig.
You wanna take it over then go ahead.
- Yeah.
So, we're talking about scaling, right?
And I wanna give you a sense
of the scale of DynamoDB.
You know, half a million
requests per second, right?
That's a lot, right?
We have hundreds of tables right now,
just right now, that are all pushing half
a million requests per second.
This is just normal for us every day.
This is what we see.
And it's not just, you know,
just barely half a million.
We've got, for instance,
the Amazon stores business on Prime Day.
They've peaked at 151
million requests per second.
That's one customer of ours.
So, a lot of the scaling causes us
to think about things a
little bit differently.
And when you combine the scale
with state in a distributed system,
this is where a lot of
the challenges come from.
You know, I'm not saying that
stateless distributed systems
are easy by any means,
but state full is a whole
nother level of complexity.
Before we get into lot of the details
of Dynamo on the specific
choices that we made.
I wanna talk about some kind of,
some of this problem in the abstract,
just kind of so we're
all on the same page.
So, if you're building an
application that has a state,
the simplest thing to do
is put the application,
the state on the same instance, right?
- [Amrith] Sorry, are you
saying that it's gonna be easy
to do this or, like, it's
like is this easy or what?
- I mean, concurrent programming
is not necessarily easy,
but relatively speaking.
Yes, I'm saying this is easier
than distributed state management.
This pattern works great
for a lot of applications,
but pretty soon you wanna scale,
you wanna scale things independently.
And so you move, you state
onto a separate instance
and now you've gotta
deal with failure, right?
Because you've got these two things now
that have to be available,
your application server
has to be available.
Now your stateful server
They both have to be available.
This is strictly less available
than the previous approach.
But you get some benefits
because you can now scale
the state and the
application independently.
But it also means that the
state can disappear out
from underneath you at any time.
And so you have to, you know, think
about these failure cases
throughout your code everywhere.
- [Amrith] So, how does your
application actually know
what the state of the
underlying database is?
- Well, in some cases it doesn't, right?
Because there's, especially
as we start scaling,
we get to the world where we say,
"Hey, one instance isn't sufficient."
You know, we're gonna
have multiple instances
and it's now we're
introducing coordination.
And coordination is where a lot
is complexity comes from, right?
And so you can end up, you know this,
one of the simplest things
you can do then is move
from a single instance model to a primary
and secondary model, right?
And this is great.
You do all your read and
rights to the primary
and, you know, you think
through this and you're like,
okay, well, I gotta deal with
when the primary fails, right?
That's easy.
Everybody thinks about when,
what happens when the primary fails-
- [Amrith] What happens to the
other side? Secondary fails.
- Oh, the secondary fails.
Yes, this one's actually more interesting
and this is one that's,
it's a little more subtle
is because what do you
do in this case, right?
Do you continue to accept
rights on the primary?
But those rights won't
end up on the secondary
because it's down.
And so what happens to those rights,
you know, when the secondary
gets healthy again?
Like how are you gonna repair all this?
And you start getting into
a lot of these corner cases
and the complexity that comes
from this distributed
state coordination, right?
And so two, right?
Well, maybe two isn't the answer.
So, three, two doesn't work.
Let's try three.
We'll just keep counting up here.
So, three is the real minimum then, right?
Right?
Well, this is great
because now if you wanna
survive a single box failing,
you can, because you still got two healthy
and you've got another one.
The right comes into one of the nodes
and you can get it to
one of the other nodes.
It's now your right's in two places.
And you, that right is
no longer susceptible
to losing a single box.
- [Amrith] If three is not
enough, what are you gonna do?
- Well, so three is not enough.
Let's try four, right?
If three is good, four must be better.
Okay, well, so with four,
you know, now in theory you can
survive two failures, right?
Because I can still get
the right to the other node
and that's fine.
But, well, no-
- [Amrith] How do you know
these two are the correct two?
- Okay, how do I know the,
yeah, so there's this failure case, right?
Like maybe all the nodes
are actually healthy
and they just can't talk to each other.
We have a network partition, right?
So, both sides think that,
well, I'm on the healthy
side, the other side's dead.
I'm gonna keep accepting rights.
And so you end up with this,
what we call "split brain"
where you've got rights, that's data,
the data set diverges over time.
And now when this partition heals,
you've got these two
totally different data sets
you have to merge.
So, having an even number
is a horrible idea.
Four is a really bad option.
- [Amrith] So, basically
the idea is you need
to have an odd number of nodes.
Is that the story?
- Yeah.
So what about five?
You know, let's just, let's
keep counting up, right?
So, four is out, we could do five.
So, with five you can
survive two failures.
Maybe that's good.
Like maybe that's what you want.
But what we've found through
a lot of our experience
is that as soon as one fails,
you're working as hard as you can
to get that replica back to par.
You're bringing a new node,
you're gonna repair the situation.
And so what you're actually doing here
for the second failure
is you're racing how fast can
I get a node healthy again
to get this cluster back to par,
back and normal before
we lose another box.
And so a lot of the effort
that goes into having
more nodes might actually
be better spent trying
to repair a node faster.
Because you're gonna need to do the repair
in this case anyways.
The-
- [Amrith] So at this point
you're basically saying you need
to have an odd number of nodes.
Is that, it's like three is okay.
Five's okay, four's not okay.
Two's clearly not okay.
Is that?
- Yeah, right.
And, you know, as you're going up,
you have to do more rights.
Like even in this world,
like you have to have the majority healthy
so that you know that
you're on the healthy side
and so you're adding more boxes.
And so you gotta think about the cost.
So, let's take this to the extreme.
Like let's say for scale reasons,
you need to have a 1000, 1,001
because it's gotta be
an odd number, right?
So, you've got 1,001.
In order to accept the right,
I've gotta have 502 boxes.
It's gotta be the
majority, except the right.
- [Amrith] Well, statistically
you can't do that.
No.
- Oh, okay.
- [Amrith] Because any one of those 500
and whatever boxes can fail.
So, if you do this, you're
gonna trade off availability.
- Yes.
It's also really expensive
because you just, like,
you've got all these,
like you really need to
write that thing 502 times
just so you know you can
survive some failures.
Yeah.
- [Amrith] So what do you do?
- So an alternative that we think
is a much better alternative
is you have lots of groups of three.
You still can have, you know, a 1000 nodes
or however many tens of thousands
nodes wherever you want.
But you do, you group the data
sets into groups of three.
Because in the groups of three,
it has all the properties we like, right?
We can replace the boxes
quickly, we know it's correct.
It's a nice odd number.
- [Amrith] How do you know
where to send a request to?
- You and your complexity?
Yeah, if I send a request,
I wanna put all these boxes
behind a Load Balancer, right?
So, the client doesn't necessarily know,
no, in this case C, F
and J are the three boxes
that are in the cluster for the data set
that this client is interested in.
But if I send a request through
a Load balancer or whatever,
it's probably gonna land somewhere else,
almost certainly as the
number of boxes goes up.
And so what K has to do then is, like,
okay, well, K can either
return or redirect
or it can proxy the, onto
the correct node for you.
But if you think about that, right,
K then just becomes the client.
Because K's gotta know the data set.
And so we have the exact
same problem to go solve
of, for this particular data set.
Where is it?
I got a lot of boxes.
- [Amrith] So, it basically,
you're gonna add one level
of indirection here and
say that every problem
in computer science can be solved
with one level of indirection
and K needs to know
where to go look this up.
Okay, fine.
All right.
- Yeah.
- [Amrith] Okay, that right.
- Okay. Have you seen these slides before?
- [Amrith] No, I have not.
You made the slides, I
haven't seen them too.
- Okay, I thought maybe.
So, yes, another level
of indirection, right?
And so we add a data set
which is the data about
where the data lives.
So, the, or metadata, right?
And so the protocol then is the client,
in order to go figure out I wanna go talk,
you know, get this particular data,
I do a lookup in metadata
and then I go get the box I
need to go connect to, right?
- [Amrith] Hmm.
Two lookups is like expensive.
- Yeah.
So, now, we're doing double lookups
and so we have to do X request per second
to the data set.
I also have to do X request
per second to the metadata set.
So, I know what you're gonna suggest next.
- [Amrith] Yeah.
There has to be an easier solution
because if you were to do this,
then you need to scale your
metadata to the same capacity
as your actual data, which
I'm not willing to do.
- Yeah.
- [Amrith] So, you need to
give me a different answer.
- So, we've got two
of our classic computer
science solutions now,
an extra layer of indirection
and caching, right?
So, if you add a cache
here between the metadata,
which is fine because these
data sets don't change
that often.
You can cache this, you have
less than X request per second
and metadata doesn't have to
scale to the same request rate.
Any snarky comments about this one?
- [Amrith] No.
Okay.
What are you gonna do
if your caches are cold
and what are you gonna do in situations
where your metadata is not able to keep up
with the uncached data?
All of those things?
- You're foreshadowing your portion
of the presentation is coming up later.
- [Amrith] Thank you for telling me
what I'm gonna talk about.
It's gonna be nice to know, okay.
- Caches can be a risk
and we'll talk about that more later.
We'll also talk about the,
how we do this routing
a little more detail.
The other thing is boxes
can still fail, right?
So, we have these large boxes,
we have to deal with this
case. And so when a box fails
and so in this case J has failed
and we wanna replace it with L.
L then has to then go
and update metadata somehow
and indicate, "Hey, I'm part of this set."
Right?
And so we have this problem, right?
This problem is, who is the authority
of which servers
participate in which groups?
Right?
You know, you think it
should be the metadata
because I'm doing all the lookups.
But you've, we've got this race
between when a box becomes
part of one of these clusters
of three and when it can serve traffic
and when it tells metadata,
and when the client
caches can recognize it.
We're talk a little
more about this as well.
- [Amrith] So, basically the
idea you're talking about
is a system which is a
system of record, authority
and something which points to it
which is potentially,
eventually consistent.
So, are you suggesting
that for scale you need
to understand eventual
consistency and deal with it?
- Yeah.
Yes.
- [Amrith] Okay.
- It's hard but-
- [Amrith] All right.
- It's hard but that's reality, right?
- [Amrith] Works for me, okay.
- But of course we've got
this magic metadata thing
we've been talking about.
What the heck is this?
Like how's that gonna work?
And there's two options here.
Like, we could just make
metadata another one
of these tables, right?
And this works great like,
but you still have that routing problem
of which subset of metadata
do I need to talk to.
And so I gotta go solve all of that again.
It makes the rights
relatively simple though
because there's only one
place I need to write to
and, you know, the system's gonna have
a lot lower request rates
because of the caches,
but it's also gonna be
significantly smaller
because all you need is
a single item to say,
"Hey, like tens of gigabytes of data
that you're looking for,
they're over there."
And so this system's gonna be multiple
of orders of magnitude smaller
in terms of data size as well.
Which opens up an alternative of instead
of having subsets of this,
you can have entire replicas, right?
If you have entire replicas,
the lookup problem gets really easy
because as a client you just have to talk
to one of the metadata nodes.
It doesn't matter which
one, but the trade off is,
it makes the right problem a lot harder
when we change the membership set.
It somehow we now have to go update all
of the metadata nodes that exist.
Because you can't predict which one
the client's gonna go talk to you later.
So, this makes it more
eventually consistent.
Oh, that was the back button.
- [Amrith] That went the
wrong way. All right.
- I apologize.
There we go.
So, through the rest of the talk
we're gonna dig into three aspects of this
and choices we've made in Dynamo,
and look at them kinda
a more tangible of what,
how did Dynamo decide to
solve some of these problems?
We're gonna look at request routing,
how the client gets to the
storage that we just described.
We'll talk about how we
structure a metadata,
but also in a system this size,
we'll talk about some of the constraints
and the limits that we
have to put into place
and why those exist.
Customers will run to these and when you,
if you understand why we think this
will help you build your applications.
So, routing.
A very simple description.
This is what Dynamo looks like.
You know, storage node fleet on the right
is what we were just talking about
with that large, you know, thousands
of nodes through with, you
know, clusters of three.
And the request router fleet is the fleet
that sends the request
to the appropriate box.
And so when a client comes in,
they get sent to a random
request router node.
And the request router has two jobs,
first one is to do authorization
and authentication.
Are you who you say you are?
Do you have access to this data?
This is where we do the SigV4 processing.
Then we also do the metadata lookup.
And from there we say,
"Okay, now I know which particular
storage node to talk to."
We forward the request on.
Okay, this picture's too simple,
there's more to it, right?
I said Load Balancers.
So, we've got Load Balancers
in front of the request routers
and they're just normal Load Balancers.
We use Network Load Balancer,
but because we have so
many Load Balancers,
we have DNS in front of the Load Balancers
because it's becomes
like the Load Balancer
of the Load Balancers.
Because it's the thing that sends traffic
to all the Load Balancers.
And of course, we're
running within a region.
Regions have availability zones.
Availability zones are
independent failure domains,
you know, availability zones
composed of multiple buildings
where the actual EC2
instances eventually run
at the end of the day. These
we're all talking about,
like, there's real hardware somewhere.
So, this separation's really important
for how we provide our
availability, durability guarantees.
Provide some challenges for latency.
So, that's what we're gonna talk about.
So, everything we have
is just an EC2 instance
at the end of the day,
which means it runs in
an availability zone.
We've been very careful
about how we've put
our servers across the
availability zone, right?
So we've striped them across
multiple availability zones.
In every availability zone,
you know, we have a choice here.
We've constrained our Load
Balancers to be within
an availability zone
because we find it easier
to think about these units of failure.
You know, this is the
choice that we've made.
And this picture's overly simplified
if you zoom in on one availability zone.
One, I think, I double
clicked on that one,
I did double click on that.
If you zoom in on one availability zone,
we've got a whole bunch of Load Balancers
and behind every Load Balancer
is a bunch of instances,
but I'm simplifying the picture.
So, if we go back to the simple picture,
like, Load Bouncer is there,
every Dynamo table is
divided up into partitions,
which we'll talk a little
bit more about later.
Every partition has three replicas
and so we've spread the replicas
across the three
availability zones, right?
And this is how we
provide our availability
and durability guarantees, right?
Because as we talked
about at the beginning,
we can lose one box, one replica
and this cluster can stay healthy, right?
A risk is if we lose two. And
so as soon as we lose one,
we're gonna try very hard to replace this.
And so we're trying to
replace the instance
as fast as possible, but a
risk is correlated failure.
And the most likely
correlated failure, we'll see,
is across an availability zone
because of, you know,
some larger scale events
because we do all of our
software deployments,
we scope them all to
individual availability zone.
We wanna make sure if two boxes fail,
they don't impact two of
the replicas in a partition.
We do this by spreading them
across availability zones.
So, this is critical to what we do,
but there's a consequence to this, right?
These availability zones, like I say,
there's, they're physical
buildings, they're connected
and you can and you should do
this is look at the distance
between some of these,
the network distance I'm talking about.
Launch two instances in
availability zone, ping them,
see what times you get,
do this in different availability zones.
You'll see it's different in
different availability zones.
Do the same thing across
availability zones.
You'll see it's different
across availability zones.
What's always true is
that the network distance
between availability zones
is significantly higher
than the network distance
within an availability zone.
And so our clients are
running on EC2 instances,
Lambda functions, you know,
containers within ECS, EKS,
whatever it is.
They're in availability zones too.
And so the simplest thing we can do
for Load Balancing is to
randomly route across all
of our available instances,
which means we're highly likely
to route a customer across
an availability zone
and back across availability zone.
So, we'll be paying
the extra latency penalty multiple times.
So, ideally, what we'd like to do is this
and use the shorter network path.
And this is meaningful
to a service like Dynamo
because if you look at the
components of our latency,
our server side processing time
is actually relatively small
and of a similar order of magnitude
to the network distance itself.
And so one of the biggest things we can do
as we work on improving
our predictable low latency over time
is shrink the distance.
We don't have to do any op,
like software optimizations
within the server itself.
We just shrink the distance.
And by shrinking the distance
that ends up with a meaningful improvement
in customer latency.
So, I said DNS is our Load
Balancer across Load Balancers.
So, if you dig, you know, do a DNS lookup
for our domain name, this
is, you know, us-west-2,
you keep doing this over and over again,
you'll get different IPs
for different Load Balancers
within the regions.
So, one of the things that we can do then
is we can do split-horizon DNS
is where you get a different answer,
depending on where the query came from.
And so if you're in one
of the availability zones,
you'll get a set of Load Balancers
in that same availability zone.
If you're in different availability zone,
you get Load Balancers from there.
And so that means that DNS
is our availability zone selector as well.
Yeah, and that's it.
Piece of cake, right?
We're all done.
Woo hoo.
Well, failure is where
this all gets hard, right?
This is what we expect to see.
This is what we like to see is.
You end up with, you know, a third
of the traffic in every availability zone.
Meaning every availability
zone processes a third
of the requests that's
relatively easy to scale
and deal with from a capacity
planning perspective.
We gotta deal with a case where
an entire availability
zone fails or we want,
you know, we wanna take it
out for whatever reason.
In that case, what we then have to do
is all the traffic from that
availability zone now has
to go somewhere because we
prioritize the availability
over the latency, right?
And so you'll notice here
that availability zone,
one and three, are now
seeing a 50% increase
in the amount of traffic
that would've had otherwise.
And so as a regional service,
this is a thing that we have
to, you know, plan for ahead of time.
And so we just have
capacity sitting there,
ready all the time.
So, the price of doing
business as a regional service
and, you know, AWS services,
you know price follows cost
and so, you know, this is baked
into the price of DynamoDB.
To be able to handle the things like this.
So customers don't have to
know under the covers that,
okay, we're dealing with an
impaired AZ at the moment.
So, that's fine.
But if you think about the case like,
well, what if the traffic
in one availability zone
is significantly larger,
we have a traffic skew.
Well, one option is we could just scale up
the number of servers in
that availability zone.
That's relatively easy, right?
But, again, think about what
happens when that one fails.
Now what you see is availability one
and availability zones, one and three,
they have to handle a doubling in traffic.
So, that idle capacity that we have
to have sitting there
ready in case of this event
is significantly larger.
So, this is a way more
expensive way for us
to run this service.
So, that would mean that we'd have
to pass on the cost to customers.
And so we don't like that option.
The alternative is what we do is we say,
"Well, we'll never send more
than a third of traffic.
This makes our DNS management
a lot more complex."
And it does mean that some requests
will always be going
cross availability zone.
In reality, you know, law of
large numbers helps us out
and we don't have a very large skew,
and so we don't really see this scenario.
We also have some traffic coming
straight from the internet.
And so the internet is close
to every availability
zone at the same time.
And so we can send that
traffic wherever we want
with more DNS complexity
so we can fill in the gaps.
But these are the types of
things you must think through
as you're building this
style of architecture.
But that's how we shrink the first top.
This is a big latency win,
but there's more, right?
Because you look about that second hop
between the request router
and the storage node.
Again, ideally we send a,
you know, third of the traffic everywhere.
From capacity planning
perspective, this is easiest.
Dynamo did this since launch.
And the, I thing, is we've
kind of baked in this model
into our capacity planning, our pricing
and our limits.
Because when you're doing
a strongly consistent read,
you must talk to a node
that we've elected leader.
So, there's only one box you can talk to,
you have the request
processing capacity of one box,
but eventually consistent reads
you can talk to any of them.
And so we said, "Okay,
well one of the boxes
might be unhealthy so
we can't count on that,
but this is, but we've got
the processing capacity
of two boxes.
That box has to be there
anyways, so let's just use it.
So, this is why an
eventually consistent reads
the limits are higher
and the price is lower,
is because we have this capacity
that would've been idle otherwise
that we can use all the time.
Actually making this
change to route locally
is pretty easy because we
control the, in this case,
we control the client and the server.
We have to know about all
three replicas anyways.
And so we just pick the one
in the same availability zone
that we are.
We send all the traffic there.
Unless of course you're
relying on this fact
that you can send two X,
the request for an
eventually assistant read
because you could now be sending
two boxes worth of traffic
to a single box.
That's no good.
And so what we have to
do is we actually have
to monitor statistics on the server side
and detect when this happens.
This happens sometimes doesn't
happen super frequently,
but when it does, we can send
a message back to the client
and say, "Hey, for this table,
let's go back to the random routing mode
because we need to prioritize availability
over the lower latency in this case."
And, again, in reality, most of the tables
that are, you know, much higher traffic,
their clients are distributed
across availability zones all the time.
And so they're being routed
to each individual availability zone,
which means that when we do the local AZ,
we see the spread that we'd expect to see.
And so we don't end up in this case
as often as you might expect.
So, this is the path on that we've taken
on how we can shrink our latency.
And a few times we've
bumped up against this,
you know, the availability
versus predictable low latency trade off.
And when forced to choose,
we're gonna make the service available.
But in a lot of cases there is no conflict
and we can do both.
It leads to a bunch of
complexity on our side,
but these are the tenets and
the most important things
for our service and for our customers.
And so we think this
complexity is worth it in order
to provide a a better
product to you folks.
- I know the next slide is, do
you want me to take this one?
- Yeah, I hope so.
- Okay.
All right.
Get a drink of water or whatever you want.
So, a couple of things
which Craig mentioned,
he talked about we do client routing
and 1/3 of the traffic goes to each AZ.
Another thing which we do is we try
and keep 1/3 of the leaders on each AZ.
Therefore even on the
strongly consistent reads,
you're evenly distributing
traffic across the ACs.
Sorry, didn't wanna interrupt you
when you were talking about it.
- [Craig] That's the first.
- All right, first time
I'm seeing these slides,
so it's gonna be interesting.
All right, so you have
a request, it comes in,
you talked about how it
goes all the way through
to the request router.
The important decision
which a request router needs
to make is, should we serve this request
and should we serve this request
as a three part question.
Are you who you claim you are?
Is your SigV4 signature
matching your request?
Do you have the permission to do the thing
which you want to do on the table,
which you're claiming you wanna do it on?
And the third one is, are
you within your limits?
So, those are the three questions
which we have to answer, each
and every request we get.
Now, we've got hundreds of customers
who do over a half a
million requests per second.
We do this stuff billions of times a day
and we have to do this really, really fast
because what are we after?
Predictable (low) latency at any scale.
That's what we're supposed to get, okay?
All right, I don't know about this crew,
but, okay, all right, thank you.
Somebody heard it?
So, we're after predictable (low) latency,
but once the request router knows
that your request is legitimate
and we do wanna serve it.
The next question which we have
to ask is, which storage
node do we send it to?
Now, Craig talked about
distributing a table
into multiple partitions and partitions
across multiple storage nodes.
We have three storage nodes here.
I, sorry, I don't have a clicker here,
but there's literally
hundreds of thousands
of storage nodes across
which we distribute data.
When I asked earlier, how
many of you use DynamoDB
or how many of you don't
use DynamoDB at this point.
Only one person raise their hands.
So, the rest of you, I
have a simple ask of you.
Look to your right.
Other right.
Okay, look to your left.
All of you who use DynamoDB,
your data is co-located on storage nodes,
which people who are next to you,
it's completely shared infrastructure.
We do not spin up a cluster for you.
So, your data is co-located
on hundreds of thousands
of storage nodes with other people's data
and hundreds of millions of times a second
we need to decide where to
send each of these requests.
So, that's the problem
which we have to solve.
Once the request makes it
to a storage node.
First, all data is
always encrypted at rest.
Anybody know why?
Shout it out if you know why?
What's the first tenet I talked about?
Come on, shout it out. I
can't hear, I don't have-
- [Crowd Member] Security.
- Thank you.
Security, all data is
always encrypted at rest.
You can provide us a key,
but if you don't provide a key,
one will be provided for you.
All data is always encrypted at rest.
So, we need to get that security that key.
Then we need to decide are
you overrunning a partition,
shared infrastructure, rate
limits, provision, throughput,
all of those kinds of things.
We need to make sure that we
want to admit the request.
So, there's two places where we decide
whether to admit your
request or throttle you.
Once we're done with that,
we have to serve your request
and your response is gonna
go from the storage node back
to the request router and back to you.
Everybody good with this flow so far?
Quick show of hands, yes or no?
All right, more than 50%.
Okay.
For those of you who used DynamoDB before.
Simple table, unique
attribute, login name,
non-unique attribute, human being's name.
So, somewhere in the middle
there, there's two people
with the same name, but they
have different login IDs.
You've all faced this problem.
The primary key on this table is login.
So, when you create a table,
we ask you for three things,
only three things.
What's the name of the table,
what's the primary key?
What's your credit card number?
Only three things.
How are you gonna pay for it?
That's your primary key.
Once you tell us what the primary key is,
we compute a hash of your primary key.
We order your data, based on the hash.
Notice that the order
of the names is different
from the order of the names on the left
because we ordered it by hashes here.
Contiguous ranges of
hashes become partitions.
Craig talked about partitioning a table
for horizontal scale.
This is partitioning for you.
Once you've partitioned the table,
if you want to fetch an item,
I need to find the partition where it is.
So, I wanna find the item for Jorge
or for Richard, or whoever.
I will compute the hash on that.
I will find which range
of hashes it falls within
and I will send my
request to that location.
Hundreds of millions of claims a second
with predictable latency.
That's the thing we're after.
So, in matter of fact,
we've built a system which will do this
in tens of microseconds.
Tens of microseconds, literally.
We measure this thing
and when it starts to
get out of this bound,
we're really antsy about it
because we do it so often.
And what we have to do
is locate the partition
where your data is.
You all right?
All right.
Look at where your traffic, data is.
And today the traffic we have
is hundreds of millions
of requests per second.
But at any point in time,
the things which we have to deal with are;
how many storage nodes do we have?
How many request orders do we have?
All these numbers are measured
in like six digits or more.
And at any point in time
you are creating tables,
you're dropping tables,
you're scaling up traffic on some table.
We're splitting a table
because of that, partitions
are moving around
and we need to figure
out where your data is
in tens of milliseconds.
Tens, sorry, tens of microseconds.
So, I wanna talk to you about
how we go about doing this.
And I wanna reiterate
effectively what I wanna get back
to is the point which Craig talked about,
which is state is hard,
shared state is really hard.
This is a distributed
system we're trying to build
where these things on the left here...
I really should get a laser pointer.
But these request
routers on the left here,
need to be able to figure
out in tens of microseconds,
which storage node your data's on.
Because those storage
nodes at the back there,
they're doing three cards, you
know shuffling all the time.
They're moving partitions around,
they're splitting partitions,
changing key ranges.
You're dropping tables,
creating new tables.
These things have to stay in sync.
All right, this is the
problem we have to solve.
So, how do we go about solving it?
These are the piece parts
which we have to deal with.
There's request routers,
there's storage notes,
there's a control plane,
create table, update table,
drop table, delete table.
And there's this thing
which you introduced called "metadata",
partition metadata, which
we're supposed to go look up.
These are the piece parts.
So, let's talk about this situation.
You create a table, you update a table.
Do a synchronous update
to partition metadata.
Yeah, this is scalable.
How often does this happen?
Relatively low volume.
Tens of thousands of times
a second, not a problem.
We can deal with this.
Partitions moving around,
partitions splitting.
Leadership moving around on storage nodes
because we're doing software deployment.
Hundreds of thousands of times a second.
If you're gonna start updating
your partition metadata,
you're building a pretty serious database
in the middle there, that in itself
will become a scalability problem for you.
The worst situation you have
is you, our customers, sending
us billions of requests,
each of which need a look
to, look up of metadata.
So, effectively this metadata system
is going to have to handle
the same front door traffic,
which DynamoDB handles.
This is not a scalable system.
So, let's look maybe at
the next obvious choice.
Any snarky comments for me?
Okay.
All right.
First option, put a cashier.
How many of you have been in a situation
where you're building a system
and somebody in your team
says, "I need to scale.
I'm gonna put a cache in there."
How often has it worked out well for you?
Caches are a great solution.
They are a dangerous solution.
And we'll talk about what, great.
So, I have a cache.
Every request router now has a cache.
Magically we've implemented one.
The size of the arrows
from the request router
that the partition metadata went down.
Let's assume this cache
has a 99% hit rate.
Okay?
Partition metadata is serving only 1%
of the front door traffic, cache misses.
Any idea what could go
wrong in the system?
Shout it out if you can.
I can hear you even if
you have headphones on.
- [Crowd Member] Stale.
- Stale, all right.
What happens if all your caches go stale?
If one cache goes stale?
Yeah, who cares?
What happens if you have a situation
where for whatever reason,
hundreds of thousands
of caches go stale.
Now your partition metadata
is gonna get hundreds
of thousands of cache misses
and it's gonna fall over.
We thought about this and said,
"Yeah, the system, yeah, maybe not."
So, we went one step further
and we also said this is a
situation of a large fleet
and a small fleet.
A large fleet of request routers
and a small fleet in partition metadata.
Could cause the small fleet to fall over.
One of the things I said when I started
was the specific choices we
made may not be relevant to you,
but there are some concepts
which you should take away.
If you're ever building a cache
and a large fleet drives a small fleet,
be very careful because
it's not gonna end well
for somebody.
All right, so this didn't work.
So, we came up with a
next generation system
where we built a two-tier cache,
where we said MEMDS is
gonna be one-tier of cache
and the request rotors are gonna
have another tier of cache.
One-tier of cache is eventual consistency.
This is now eventual consistency
on top of eventual consistency.
So, keep that in mind when I say this.
You create a table,
we're gonna push it down
to MEMDS, great.
There's gonna be a polar there,
which is gonna go read all
the storage now and say,
"What partitions do you
have for what tables?"
Great, I'll push it to MEMDS.
Great.
This is now, MEMDS is now an
eventually consistent cache.
You make a request on the request router.
If it gets a cache miss, it goes to MEMDS,
which is itself eventually
consistent cache.
This is the system we built,
and let me tell you
why I think this works.
Control plane, push new table creation.
Great.
The one thing which we
added here is we version
the data across the board.
Whenever there's new data in the place
of a, you talked about
place of authority, right?
Yes.
The authority is the storage nodes.
The storage nodes know what data they are.
They're your storage node.
Do you know what partitions
you have? Absolutely you do.
So, if the partition
publisher comes to you
and asks you what partitions do you have,
you will give an absolutely
authoritative answer.
That's now pushed to MEMDS,
but that is the state
at that point in time.
But you also say,
my version is now version
20 or something like that.
At some point, if you wanna move
a partition to one place to another,
or there's a split,
comes to the same thing.
Bump the version number.
So, here's what we did.
A storage node had version 20 of metadata.
It split a partition,
it moved a partition.
The new storage node says,
"I'm now at version 21."
Now, if a request were to
come in to the front door,
the storage node says I have
a cache value, which says 20.
Maybe it had a cache missing,
it went to MEMDS and
MEMDS said, "Value of 20."
It doesn't matter.
It goes to the place where
version 20 pointed it to.
Version 20 is the authoritative source
and it says, "Eh-eh, not gonna work."
You actually need to
go to this other place
because now we're at 21.
The immediate thing
which we do is the new,
the request is gonna go
straight to the new place
and it is gonna get served immediately.
So, even if you have
eventually consistent data
in this system, like the
caches are two-tier steep
and eventually consistent.
If you do have a cache miss,
which happens infrequently
because there's a partition split
or a partition move,
we are still able to serve
that in reasonable time.
If you are interested in how
all of this stuff's supposed
to work, we published a paper about this.
That's a QR code, scan it.
Actually, this is not being recorded,
so you probably wanna scan it.
Or if you want to contact me afterwards.
The basic idea is this.
You've got a system with
data which has entropy.
You have a need to do stuff with caches,
and these caches are gonna
be eventually consistent
and they need to deal with the situation
where all the caches can probably go cold.
So, far I've talked about the first two,
I haven't talked about the last one.
So, let's talk about that one.
System of record, authoritative there,
two levels of eventually
consistent caches.
We're good so far.
Now, let's talk about the situation
with large fleet, small fleet and hedging.
If you are ever building a system
and you want predictable latency.
Use this concept called "Hedging."
We do it internally.
When a request arrives...
By the way, hedging is not our idea.
It's a idea from Google,
that's a copy of the paper up there.
When a request shows
up at a request router.
In the eventuality that we
have a miss on the cache,
we don't make one request,
we make two requests to two MEMDS servers.
Why is this a good idea?
Assume that your system
is like most systems
and your latency is along some
kind of normal distribution.
If you make two requests,
statistically one's on the left
of the median, one's on
the right of the median.
Take the first response.
It's always good.
We hedge our requests.
What this means is that in the
eventuality of a cache miss,
so far,
(Amrith coughs)
MEMDS is serving twice the traffic
which we're getting for cache miss.
We go one step further.
What happens if all the
caches happen to be cold?
We introduce this
concept of constant work.
You make a request to DynamoDB,
that request goes through Load
Balancers and all that stuff,
shows up at a request router.
The request router says,
"Where's this item?
The cache is correct."
It makes a request to the storage node.
The storage node serves a response.
We've already given you the answer.
What do we do in the background?
We send two requests to two MEMDS servers,
even on a cache hit.
Everybody with me?
On a cache hit,
we send two requests to two MEMDS servers.
Why?
Assume someday all the caches went cold?
MEMDS would not know the difference.
Large fleet, small fleet,
this is the cost to us
of doing business
and giving you predictable
(low) latency at any scale.
These are the things which we keep in mind
when we build our systems,
and we try to build systems
with a guarantee of availability.
We can't just say your cache is cold,
therefore we had loss of availability.
Can't do that.
The latency needs to be not just low,
but predictably low.
These are some of the considerations
which we had to go through
because these were our tenets.
Figure out what your tenets are
and have your decisions
mirror your tenets.
You're not gonna probably
have to make the same choices,
but in the event that you do,
my suggestion to you is
be very, very careful
of the person who says, "We'll
add a cache in front of it
and it's gonna solve all the problems."
Caching is damn hard.
I've been doing this for about 35 years.
The number of times
when somebody has said,
"I'll put a cache in front of it
and life is gonna be good."
The number of times they're
wrong is close to a 100%.
Caching is hard.
But if you do understand
that you wanna have caching,
understand eventual consistency.
Build systems with version data
so that eventually consistent
data is your friend.
Don't run away from it and say,
"I need synchronous upgrades
across large numbers of node"
because that is not a scalable solution.
Eventual consistency is your friend
if you want to go to scale.
Why are these things important for us?
Because our tenants were security,
durability, availability.
Great.
Predictable (low) latency at any scale.
If we want any scale,
we need to understand
eventual consistency ourself.
Everybody good so far?
I've talked a lot about caching.
I've talked a lot about the
things we do on a request order.
What are the things we cache?
You wanna connect to
DynamoDB and make a request.
We cache your identity credentials.
You wanna make a request
on some particular table.
We cache your table metadata.
Suppose you were to make a new connection
to DynamoDB on every request.
You're probably going
to a new request router.
Are you gonna get the benefit of caching?
No.
Make sure you have a
long lived connection.
What does that mean?
Right size your connection pool.
If you have low traffic,
have a small connection pool.
If you have high traffic,
it's okay to have a
larger connection pool.
If you have a very
small amount of traffic,
don't have a huge number of hosts
who are serving you that traffic.
Think about these kinds of things
to make sure that you get
predictable (low) latency.
Also, if you want
predictable (low) latency
from your application,
hedge your requests.
Send two requests.
If their rights, make
sure they're item potent.
If they're reads,
eventually consistent reads.
Choose the first one,
don't change the timeout.
And if you are building
caches, please by all means,
build constant work into your plan.
The other thing which we did in order
to give you predictable (low) latency
is this whole concept
of limits in DynamoDB.
And there's numerous limits we have here.
I'm gonna talk quickly
about a couple of these.
There's read and write limits.
The motivation for all
of the limits we have
is predictable latency,
because at the end of the day,
DynamoDB is running on physical hardware.
Physical hardware has limitations,
and this hardware is
shared infrastructure.
We have to make sure
that we operate a service
which is cost effective to us,
so we can translate those
benefits over to you.
So at the end of the day,
we've got physical hardware
with some limitations on it.
If you create a table
and that table had some
number of provisioned RCUs.
In the old days, this is historical,
we would divide that table
into some number of partitions.
When we split that table,
unfortunately we divided the provisioning
onto those two partitions.
This was called IOPS dilution.
The reason we have this
up here is there's a bunch
of people who've been using
DynamoDB for a long time
who think this is still a problem.
This is no longer a problem.
The way things work today,
if you've got a number of
partitions and we split a table.
When we split the partitions,
each partition gets the
same partition level limit.
Currently the limits are
a 1000 WCUs and 3000 RCUs.
The numbers may change over time.
Don't take a commitment on those.
But we have those
because we want to guarantee
predictable latency.
I will make one small detour here.
A lot of customers ask me,
"What is the partition count on my table?"
This is a meaningless
metric for you to ask us.
And the reason is simply this.
If you were to have a table,
there's no guarantee that each table has
the same fraction of the key range.
Each partition has the same
fraction of the key range.
The real question you're asking is,
"I have a big cyber
sale, Cyber Monday sale
in a couple of days.
Is my table gonna be able
to serve my traffic?"
The question you need to ask us is this.
If I have a different
size for each partition,
I just made up these numbers here,
which partition is
gonna throttle me first?
The real question is that partition there
is the one which is gonna throttle you.
So, just telling you that you happen
to have eight partitions
is gonna do nothing for you
because eight times 3000 or 8,000,
1000 is useless to you.
So we introduced this feature,
which was partition,
table warm throughput.
To answer this exact question,
I have a major event coming up.
Is my table gonna be able
to serve my traffic or not?
So, warm throughput is a
feature which we launched.
We launched it last year at re:Invent.
Describe a table, it'll
tell you what the traffic is
that you can serve without throttling.
Similar limit, which we have.
Transaction size limit.
When we launched DynamoDB,
a transaction could have
no more than 25 items.
Today we have a 100.
We offer standard asset transactions.
If you built a relat,
built stuff with a relational database,
we have the same transactions for you.
It allows you to build
banking applications.
All of the guarantees which you want.
But our transactions are different.
We have two kinds of transactions.
We have read-only transactions
and writeable transactions.
All of the items in the transaction
are specified at one time.
All of these things
are things which we did
because we want predictable (low) latency.
Have you ever been in a situation
where your application is hung
because somebody started a
transaction and went to coffee?
Cannot happen in DynamoDB
because the transaction
contains all of the changes
which are gonna happen in one place.
We offer standard serializable isolation.
If you're built applications
with relational databases,
you understand this.
We use the standard
two-phase commit approach,
standard two-phase
commit, prepare, commit.
Everything is standard the
way in which you would expect
with a two-phase commit transaction.
We do those things.
We did do one optimization for reads.
We do not do two-phase commit for reads
because it's cheaper for us
to just do the read two times.
If the items didn't change,
your transaction is good.
The question is then, why do
we have transaction limits?
Why 25?
Why 100?
And the simple answer is this.
We want predictable (low) latency.
We did a bunch of testing and we said,
"If we increase the number
of items in a transaction,
what happens to latency and
what happens to availability?"
If you have contention on your items,
which are being modified
in the transaction,
availability goes down, latency goes up.
When we launched, we were
able to safely do 25.
Today we're able to do 100.
We wanna increase the number even further.
These are some of the reasons
why we have limits on transactions.
Similarly, item size limits.
Why do you have an item
size limit of 400 kilobytes?
Well, it's shared infrastructure.
We wanna make sure that you
do not impact your own usage
on some other item, which
is in the same partition.
As the num, size of the item goes up.
The number of times you can read
or write that goes down.
The number of times,
the amount of time it
takes is gonna go up.
We have item size limits
of 400K for a limit.
If you do need a larger number,
I'd love to talk to you about it.
We have limits on GSIs,
global secondary indexes.
When we launched, it was five.
Today the number is 20.
The reason is we want
predictable (low) latency.
Am I going backwards or forwards?
I have no idea, okay.
Today is 20.
We were able to make
changes to the software
so that we gave you consistent,
predictable replication lag to the GSIs.
Today the number is 20.
Why do you have GSIs?
Because you have
alternate access patterns.
Now, of course, if you have
a need for more than 20 GSIs,
that's my email address.
Please do contact me
because I think there's
a different conversation
we need to have about your schema.
Many of these decisions we took,
every one of the limits
were to give you predictable (low) latency
because I think that's the one
thing which differentiates us
from any other database.
Predictable (low) latency at any scale.
So, I'm gonna kind of...
Oh, I came to the end of this pretty good.
So, conclusion is we
talked about the tenets.
Every one of the decisions
we make as a team
is based on our tenets.
These are our high level tenets.
Whenever we have a project,
whenever we have a new feature,
whenever we have a new thing
which we want to develop,
one of the things which
we ask the team is,
"What are your tenets?"
Because those are the things
which help distribute decision
making across the team,
and they make sure that the teams are able
to iterate faster.
But as a service, these are our tenets.
If you ever have a question
why we did something,
the answer's probably one of these four.
Why did you not store your
data unencrypted on disk?
Because it'll be faster.
First one up there.
Why don't we give you some
other right guarantee,
other than we will write
the two availability zones
and it'll be faster, won't it?
Durability.
We are a regional service.
We guarantee that if a
complete availability zone
were to go away, we will not
be in the least bit impacted.
Your data is written to two
AZs before we commit it to you.
Availability is our third guarantee.
There's no point having
availability with wrong data
or giving your data to the wrong person.
Security, durability, then availability,
and to us, as a service,
predictable (low) latency.
So, my ask to you would be this.
In the projects you are
building with DynamoDB,
without DynamoDB, it doesn't matter.
Think about these things.
What are your tenets?
How do you drive decision
making in your organization?
This is how we drive it in ours.
So, I hope this was useful to you.
We're gonna hang around here
and answer any questions,
but apparently if you want a hoodie,
you have to come and talk to somebody
in the database booths.
There's no QR code here.
There's a whole bunch of
trainings which we do offer.
The one other ask I have of you of this.
One other ask I have of you is this.
We do these presentations
because we believe it's
really important to share
with you the things which
we have learned operating
a service at scale,
and making the choices,
which we made and learning from you.
A part of it is standing here
and talking to you about these things,
but a part of it is listening to you
after these conversations.
But if you want more content
like this at re:Invent,
please do fill the feedback sessions.
Thank you very much.
I think that's the last one.
(crowd clapping)